[Música]
la vida de vilar hace nueve años dio un
vuelco su padre Fue encarcelado en un
centro de retención en China y ante el
miedo de ir también a prisión por formar
parte de La minoría
a Turquía donde inició una nueva vida
estábamos tristes cuando salimos de
china porque habíamos abandonado nuestra
casa pero al llegar a Estambul vimos que
podíamos construir aquí una nueva vida
que aquí podíamos estar seguros nadie
nos obliga a nada nadie nos hace nada
Durante los últimos años Estambul se ha
convertido en Un refugio para miles de
exiliados y perseguidos de países de
Asia central y Oriente próximo
[Música]
mikel una bailarina iraní ha escogido al
país San Antonio como otros exiliados
por ser más libre que el resto de sus
vecinos en Irán su oficio está prohibido
como mínimo en Turquía puedo bailar
claro no es como en Europa como los
Estados Unidos como Canadá lo sé pero en
Turquía como mínimo puedo bailar es lo
que más quiero en este mundo y si no
pudiese bailar no estaría aquí si no
pudiese Me sentiría como enferma
las libertades en Turquía sin embargo
tienen un límite hay más nuevos
propietario de alshark televisión
egipcia en el exilio que transmite sin
censura desde 2015 contra el gobierno
egipcio de abdelfatán al Sisi recibió
advertencia de oficiales turcos de
vigilar su mensaje tras el acercamiento
de Turquía con el militar egipcio no
queremos que nos afecte la mejora de
relaciones entre los gobiernos de
Turquía y Egipto pero en caso de que
pueda pasar Egipto debe saber que nos
moveríamos a otro país donde no haya
límites con más libertades y creo que
saben que esto no les ayudaría
su lucha sin embargo sigue para nur y
sus 150 trabajadores Estambul se ha
convertido en su hogar a pesar de los
retos y las presiones